today's questions from Collin in Texas
I'm looking to open a checking and
savings account with an online bank been
looking at Discover and American Express
I want to know what you thought of those
banks or is there a different online
bank you recommend thank you
well I don't do business with anything
that has an American Express on the
front of it because they once asked my
wife why she would stay with a man that
wouldn't pay his bills and she called me
crying and said she was thinking the
same thing so I'm done with them
that's what happens when a hillbilly
gets mad that was 37 years ago I'm still
pissed okay so I don't do any business
with American excess under any
circumstances and I really don't like
doing business with Visa but I have a
Visa debit card through my bank Discover
pretty much has one goal in life and
that's debt so I'm not sure why I would
use them as my bank so overall both of
them sound like credit card companies to
me not banks and my tendency would be to
stay away from them for those reasons
now what I use an online bank
exclusively there's nothing wrong with
that if you check out their background
and so forth I am a little bit more
old-school and I use a what you would
call a click and mortar bank a bank that
is a traditional bank but has tremendous
online capabilities and so I've got both
however I've not been inside of a bank
in probably years because of two reasons
one is I don't have any need to go in
I'm spoiled rotten
I have an accounting team here that does
all of my transactions I don't go to
banks I don't need to so I've just
spoiled that's what that means I don't
even go over there to the posit my own
stuff other people do that right so that
kind of thing so I'm a little bit of a
weirdo in that sense so I don't need a
actual physical location most of us do
transactions now ninety something
percent of our transactions are online
so there's nothing wrong with an online
bank I haven't chosen that route
personally so I don't have
recommendation for you the other thing I
look for in a bank is I actually want
human beings around even if it's online
that I can have somewhat of a
connectivity to that's why I don't
recommend you do Bank business with the
super huge banks the Wells Fargo's the
Bank of America is where you're pretty
much a number and they couldn't give a
rip less if you're there especially
unless you're borrowing money and so I
use community banks and credit unions
those are the two things I endorse in a
lot of communities around America when
you turn on the Dave Ramsey show you'll
hear my voice which we don't put my
voice on stuff I don't believe in and
haven't shat our team hasn't checked out
in detail and so a lot of community
banks a lot of credit unions have my
voice on it and a lot of those have very
high-end online experiences and so again
you get a click and mortar you get the
benefit of a location where you can walk
in and you know Sally the you know or
George the the teller and you get to
know them over the years like in the old
days if you're regularly making a
physical deposit or withdrawal or
something you can do that you actually
know the branch manager like in the old
days and they actually in the smaller
banks actually they actually have more
power a Bank of America branch manager
has less power than the teller in terms
of waiving NSF fees or you know taking
care of a problem or something moving
some money or they really are their
ability they can't even approve a car
loan I mean at the local level they're
just all the decision making is
decentralized and so in the old days a
banker was a pillar in the community and
they had a lot of power to make
decisions now a banker is a joke in
these large banks they they know that
truly they have nothing it's like an
entry-level position
it's a horrible position honestly if
you're a branch manager from Bank of
America I'm sorry for you I really it's
pitiful and so of course I'm obviously
don't like Bank of America I don't know
why anybody in this business there Wells
Fargo they just make up accounts and put
them on I mean and fired well they fire
thousands and thousands of people for
fraud you know so yeah just that's
that's my thing so online banking is
okay I don't
personally do it so I can't really tell
you to go do it because I'm not
hypocritical I love the small the
regional bank and credit union and
that's where I would send you